something so extraordinary is happening
on this planet I mean you know for
hundreds of millions of years biology
flowed across the surface and species
advanced and retreated and sensory
organs were refined and redefined and so
forth and so on but about thirty five
fifty thousand years ago language broke
loose and language is the shear will of
information itself to transform itself I
mean we are our medium is meat but we
are made of information you know and
that information could be fed into a
computer crystallized into a virus what
we are is a long message that is being
typed out in proteins by thousands of
ribosomes coordinated over time we are
sort of like a phonograph record and
when you're young you know certain
enzyme systems certain genes are turned
on and then you pass into midlife other
genes are turned on certain genes are
turned off it's like a melody theme and
variation being brought back the theme
being enriched and worked and then
finally the whole thing builds to a
crescendo and then one by one the genes
are turned off and the audience tugs on
its overcoats cabs are hailed and
people go home for the evening but that
that's what you are you're a story a
piece of code being run in the great
computer of of the world but nothing
lasts you know not your friends not your
enemies
nothing lasts and we deny this and yet
that's the great psychedelic truth and
if you can face it in every moment and
live it you will have a very very
complete experience of existence you
will ride the DAO towards the conquest
sense and be able to live in the light
of its anticipation and this I believe
makes for a healthy life full of lots of
laughs I mean what are we to make of
ourselves whether mankind are we to be
ultimately viewed as a cosmic accident
the the perils of unfocus intelligent or
can we reflect the inner dream the inner
image of wholeness that inspires us and
makes us more than animals and raises us
up as a simulacrum of the goddess that's
what I would hope for and thought
cognition planning caring emotion
communication intentionality focus and
authenticity are the domains that we
have to be in in order to carry this off
you want a challenge some of you have
made fortunes that was no challenge you
wanted a challenge save the planet
there's a challenge that's what
everybody who came before did they
participated sufficiently at least to
pass the buck to us can we participate
sufficiently to pass the buck to our
grandchildren or are we just going to go
down as the lamest generation in the
life of the planet I can't believe it I
know too many of these people I love too
many of these people we just need to do
our best as the Grateful Dead say you
know just a little bit harder just a
little bit more you can't go back and
you can't stand still if the Thunder
don't get you that the light men will so
forward into the future with a high
heart and reasonable hope that we can
make this planet into a living
reflection of the inner dream
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]